una foto para la historia
Ucrania y la Unión Europea iniciaron su
cumbre en kiev en medio de la guerra su
objetivo evitar la caída de la economía
ucraniana este 2023 la ayuda europea
debería alcanzar los 9 mil millones de
euros cuatro veces más que en 2022
reports
esto es algo muy bueno son préstamos a
muy largo plazo que la Unión Europea
otorga a Ucrania pero no se trata de
reconstrucción Esto es para mantener a
flote la economía de Ucrania en una
situación desesperada
[Música]
este dinero Está destinada a fortalecer
sectores energéticos claves como gas y
electricidad Además del transporte y Los
agronegocios gravemente afectados por el
conflicto en el verano de 2022 el
bloqueo de los puertos del mar Negro por
parte del ejército ruso provocó Un
aumento en el precio del trigo antes de
volver a su nivel anterior a la guerra
militarmente la Unión Europea va muy por
detrás de los Estados Unidos en envíos
de armas y municiones 30 mil millones
para el Aliado estadounidense contra 13
mil millones para Bruselas a pesar de la
ayuda masiva Ucrania necesitará de mucho
más para financiar su reconstrucción
total estimada hoy en alrededor de 500
mil millones de dólares